flying last summer was brutal we we
almost missed a show because we got
stuck at the Denver Airport for [__]
10 hours so many flights last summer
just cuz they just they were underst
staffed and a lot of flights too you
have a flight booked and I feel like the
airline knew they're over booking people
I we we were on the road in like South
Carolina I just get it we're supposed to
fly home together I'm like dude they
moved me to Atlanta I'm like this is
crazy they moved my flight 10 hours and
then I'm walking over and I pass this
other flight who I'd seen that happen
the same thing had happened to them and
they're all waiting and the guy gets on
and goes I know you guys are going to be
mad but the flight is here the pilots
are here we cannot fight any flight
attendant so we can't go anywhere and
then people just [__] start screaming
and going crazy I feel like everyone is
just on it and that's when we get very
disrespectful towards flight attends
where we're like do we even need them on
the flight like if we have the pilots
aren't we okay if we all agree if I was
on that flight I would have said [__]
take off I'll pass out the peanuts or
how about no peanuts